problem 51
actually let me
scroll all the way up problem 51.
they drew a little triangle here which i
assume i need so i'll draw it as well
that side side is flat
and then the side goes down like that
and then they draw some angles
if this is being angle x
this is angle y
this is angle z
and they say what is the value of z in
the triangle above fair enough
statement number one
is
x plus y
is equal to 139
well as soon as you see a triangle you
have to figure out one side you should
always remember that the sum of the
angles of a triangle add up to 180 so we
know that x
plus y
plus z is equal to 180.
statement 1 just told us that x y is
equal to 139
so we know from statement 1 that this is
so that would just make this equation
plus z is equal to 180 which is very
easy to solve subtract 39 from both
sides would you get z is equal to 41 or
something like that it doesn't matter
you don't have to get the answer you
just have to know that you can get the
answer so statement one alone is enough
now what do they give us in statement
number two
statement two
y
plus z is equal to 108.
this statement alone is useless i mean i
we don't know what y is so we can't
figure it out i mean one thing is true
if you if you had both of these
statements then you could figure out all
of the angles of the triangle because
you know you know the z is 41 then you
could figure out y then you could you
know y then you can figure out x by
using but that's they're not asking us
that they're asking we need to figure
out what angle z is and this statement
alone will not tell us what angle z is
because we don't know what angle y is
but statement 1 alone works so the
answer is a
next problem
let me turn the page
if x
y and z are non-zero so x
y
or z do not equal zero you know they
could have written x times y times z
does not eq is not does not equal 0
because that's the same thing because if
any of them were 0 it would have been
equal 0.
so i could have written x y z
does not equal 0. because if you
multiply 3 non-zero numbers it's not
going to equal 0.
but anyway they're asking is x z is
equal to is it equal to 12 xz equal to
is the question
statement 1 tells us and i'll do it in a
different color
to ease the monotony
statement 1 tells us that x squared
times y
z
is equal to 12
x
y
so let's see what we can do what if we
were to divide both sides of this
equation by xy
so if you get let's divide both sides by
x first so if you divide both sides by x
and we can do that because we know that
x does not equal 0.
so then you get divide both sides by x
you get x
y z is equal to 12
y right divided by x on both sides now
let's divide both sides by y you get x
z is equal to 12. and we're done
statement alone is enough and remember
the only reason why we were able to
divide both sides by y is because we
knew it didn't equal 0.
now what does statement 2 tell us
statement 2 tells us that z
over 4 is equal to 3
over x and here we can cross multiply x
times z is equal to 3 times 4.
and if that didn't make sense you could
do it one step at a time multiply both
sides by 4 you get
z is equal to
over x just multiply both sides by 4.
now multiply both sides by x and you get
x z
is equal to 12.
so each statement independently is
enough to solve the equation so that's
that's
d i always have to keep looking back and
looking at which letter i have to say i
should memorize that you should at least
you have to take the gmat
all right 53
a certain company currently has how many
employees so we want to know the number
of amps
how many employees
okay so statement number one
if three additional employees are hired
by the company and all of the present
employees remain there will be at least
there will be at least 20 employees in
the company so let's say e is the number
of employees today
so e
plus three so the current number of
employees and three additional are hired
and all of them remain there will be at
least 20 employees in the country so at
least tells us
greater than or equal to 20 employees
that's what statement one is and that by
itself doesn't tell me how many
employees are at the company it tells us
that there are at least 17 employees at
the company but it doesn't tell us
anything else i mean you can subtract
three from both sides and you say e is
greater than or equal to 17 but e could
be a hundred i don't know okay statement
two
if no additional employees are hired by
the company and three of the present
employees resign
so e
minus 3
there will be fewer than 15 employees at
the company
so
fewer
fewer than 15 employees so not 15 or
lower they say 15
fewer than 15. so
less than 15.
right here they said at least 20. so
that's greater than or 20 greater than
or equal to here they said fewer than
they didn't say 15 or fewer they said
fewer than 15. so if you simplify this
you get
add 3 to both sides you say e is less
than
18.
so let me ask you a question well first
of all this by itself isn't helpful
because this just tells us we could have
only five employees at the company or we
could have ten this doesn't tell us by
itself but if we use both of these in
conjunction
if we know that e
is less than so if we say 17
is less than or equal to e i just wrote
this in a different order right 17 is
less than or equal to e which is less
than 18 i'm using both statements
what is e
well it has to be greater than or equal
to 17. so it could be 17 can it be 18
well no because that's to be less than
18. so e has to be 17. so both
statements together are needed to solve
this problem
and that is
c both statements together are
sufficient
next problem
let me erase this little 5 i drew here
54.
all right what is the value of n in the
equation
minus 25
plus 19
plus
n is equal to
s
well just to simplify it and we could
add up minus 25 plus 19 you get what you
get uh
you get
minus six so you get n minus 6 is equal
to
s
all right that's right actually you
don't have to do this remember your
whole problem the whole point of this is
figure out whether you can solve the
problem you don't always have to solve
it but i'm solving them here just to
to prove it to you
to give you the intuition of when you
can solve it so if you add 6 to both
sides so anyway this is just a
simplification let's read the statements
i haven't read them yet maybe i didn't
have to do any of that
all right what problem was i l54
okay s is equal to 2.
well clearly if we know what s is equal
to two we can solve for n n would be
equal to eight this statement alone is
sufficient
now problem number statement number two
tells us
n
over s is equal to four
well once again
as long as we have some relation with n
and s and we could solve for n for
s and then substitute back in we can
solve for n and to prove it let me do it
we have n is equal to 4s
n is equal to 4s and then if we know
that n is equal to 4 what are we doing
we're trying to solve for n
so we could also divide we could write s
is equal to
n divided by 4. and then you can
substitute back into that equation so
then you would get
n is equal to s which is n over 4
plus 6 and then you could just solve for
n and if you want to do it let's see
multiply both sides by 4 you get 4n
is equal to n
plus 24 that's an equal sign not not
equal
4n i just multiplied both sides by 4. 4n
is equal to n plus 24. subtract n from
both sides you get 3n is equal to 24
and then you get n is equal to 8 again
so each statement alone
is sufficient and that is i should
really memorize this that's d
each statement alone is sufficient
okay let's see we have time for 55 let
me wait for that for the next video see
you soon